[Music]
314
000 new infections in a single day
it's the worst coronavirus outbreak for
any country
india's hospitals are close to collapse
they're running out of medication and
oxygen
2 000 people died on wednesday alone
india had come off relatively lightly
during the pandemic
but the number of infections has
rocketed in recent weeks
[Music]
why is the big question some doctors
blame more infectious
variants others point to loose
restrictions and people letting down
their guard
after hearing about the vaccine or
following india's fairly unscathed brush
with the first wave
we'll talk to an expert in delhi in a
moment first this report
many in india thought they had got the
better of the pandemic
but now the country is being overwhelmed
by a devastating new wave
no city is as badly hit as delhi
as cases explode hospitals there are at
breaking point
some patients are forced to share a bed
and there's an acute shortage of oxygen
the city's chief minister says the
system has reached its limits
the beds for covid19 patients are
filling up rapidly
patients are being admitted to the
hospitals very quickly
intensive care beds are in short supply
and less than 100 icu beds are available
in delhi
authorities in delhi had already imposed
a lockdown over the weekend
ordering orbit essential services to
close
local leaders hope the decision to step
up the measures
will help to mitigate the crisis some
welcome the restrictions
but others fear if they're not allowed
to work the consequences
could be drastic
it is essential that there's a lock down
here because right now
the virus is spreading a lot
the problem with the lockdown is us
daily wage earners who get 100 to 300
rupees a day
where will we go how will we eat where
will we sleep
is the government going to come and give
us this daily wage
but now with one in three tests in delhi
turning out positive
the government says it must act to avert
a greater disaster
the fear is that the surging cases is
due to a new more infectious variant of
the virus
they're calling on people to be more
disciplined about sticking to the rules
but critics are also asking why
religious festivals
and political rallies that are fueling
cases
as participants return to cities like
delhi are still being allowed
to go ahead
for tens of thousands of families such
questions
come too late and if current trends
persist
then many more will find themselves in
the same tragic
situation
rajiv dasgupta is chair of the center of
social medicine and community health at
jawaharlal
nehru university just how tragic is the
situation what have you been
experiencing
well in short the situation is extremely
distressing
particularly for those who require bed
or oxygen support or intensive care
support
it is also very troubling given that the
number of cases are continuing to rise
and as the report just said the test
positivity rate
is nearly 30 percent that that goes on
to show
that this trend is going to continue for
some foreseeable weeks
the numbers are absolutely awful let's
just take a little look at them
out of one and a half billion people
have been over 15 million
cases and more than 265 000 infections
a day what's your explanation
well the most common explanation is one
of negligence or complacency
but that's not the entire explanation
because even in the first phase it's not
that
the preventive behaviors or preventive
practices
were absolutely top order they weren't
as very limited
behavioral surveys and the fact is that
the surveys were limited
has shown what is important is that
the cases began to rise with
coinciding with the import of the uk
strain
first first identified in the last week
of december
which significantly led to rise in the
northern indian state of punjab
as well as identification of local
homegrown variants the b1617 as we now
know
which which later went on to become the
double mutant as it's popularly known as
the point is that these two have spread
incredibly fast
and have simply outstripped the health
services
what about some of these political
rallies and festivals turning into
so-called super spreader events i mean
what's to celebrate when
so many people are dying
now the fact that the disaster
management act the national disaster
management act remains in force in the
country
uh belies explanations
why events of this scale were actually
happening
allowed by the administ by the local
administrations in fact
several of the medical associations
doctors bodies
had written have already written to the
election commission of india
drawing attention to these rallies and
it's only belatedly if i may
the election commission put its foot
down limiting it to 500
uh per person sorry per congregation
is it the government or or is it the
people the people who decide to go along
to these
rallies and events well both certainly
because the disaster management act is
enforced there's a very
detailed uh standard operating procedure
for
various congregations whether you
whether it's a wedding whether it's a
whether it's a cremation uh
how much how many seeds for example can
be occupied in a cinema hall
how many seats can be filled up in a bus
how many have to be empty in a cafe and
so on and so forth
so there is no death of these details of
these procedures
rajiv what happened to lessons learned
from the first wave and from
so many other places that have had the
third or fourth waves this is only the
second wave
and we're talking about the biggest rise
in infections worldwide
well the experience both from this
pandemic in other countries
as well as earlier influenza pandemics
is that the second wave
almost inevitably is very big and that's
largely because
young adults get affected which is
exactly the
feature here in the in the earlier phase
in february in some of the districts of
maharashtra the western indian state
including the financial capital mumbai
uh in some of these states the test
positivity rate has been as high as 50
percent
in fact 50 plus that goes on to show
that it is the variance spreading very
fast
and not though not necessarily fatal
though not necessarily more fatal
but because they're more transmissible
led to a burst of cases which completely
outstripped medical services and
therefore leading to
some excess mortality rajiv just briefly
and finally can you offer indians
watching our show today some
some sort of hope
well the the state and the courts
have often taken a contrarian position
of lives versus livelihoods
the the supreme court today also took
sure motor cognizance of that
uh urging the government to consider it
as a national
emergency and we hope that these
emergency measures would be pretty
put in pretty fast both state and
central governments and local bodies
have
gone back to their drawing boards but it
could still take
a couple of weeks perhaps to offer some
sucker
magic descriptor thank you very much for
being on the show today joining us
from delhi there thank you
and time to hand you over to our very
own derek williams he's got a viewer
question on
you guessed it vaccines
is the first dose of a vaccine different
from the second one
almost all of the dozen or so vaccines
now going into arms
around the world are are given in two
doses with the
recommended interval between them
depending on the vaccine
between two and 12 weeks
the ways that different vaccines provoke
an immune response
vary some are based on messenger rna
that causes your cells
to make the sars to spike protein
others smuggle the same genetic
information into the body
packed in harmless adenoviruses that act
like
taxis into your cells while some of the
chinese vaccines
employ a more traditional platform a
full
version of the coronavirus that's been
inactivated
in nearly all of the two dose vaccines
the two shots
administered are identical though there
is
an exception to that rule the doses of
the russian sputnik v
vaccine are made with two different
adenoviruses
that cause colds although both have been
genetically engineered to carry the same
sars kobe 2 spike protein genes
the vaccine was designed that way to
ensure
that the booster shot so the second one
would work
even if recipients developed a strong
immune response
to the carrier virus in the first dose
other trials based on the same principle
which is called
heterologous prime boost they're also
now going on
with other vaccines some of those trials
are combining
different vaccines in different ways to
see whether that might make the immune
response
to sars kov2 even stronger
or or more lasting
now here's something i wouldn't try at
home the french are known for their
protest culture and
that hasn't stopped in the pandemic just
take the
lingerie shops which have protested by
sending the prime minister
their panties the 80 independent
underwear stores want their businesses
classed as essential
allowing them to stay open during
lockdowns owners say
there's more to their business than sexy
bed wear well fitting products are
essential for the likes of pregnant
women for example
they need a bit of extra support of
course they hope an
avalanche of protest panties will change
the pm's mind
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon
you